yeah you know when to welcome to this
video playing our Kaaba in the house
explains see 3 yeah okk I didn't really
have this on the radar okay let's play
this line which is fairly ambitious and
it's about what I know I came home go
fullscreen tried hmm ok yeah I made my
development isn't all that grade quickly
the quick night a 3 B 5 and so on it
could be can be a problem I don't know I
don't like to trade Queen Sam but I
don't know what else to do I mean I can
take the form he's threatening Bishop c4
maybe okay I'm training hmm not happy
here it looks a bit awkward my ass got
not with five I think mmm I need to
probably be ready to just give up my
bishop pair there might be five I have
to take it yeah this is an excellent
opening result for quite a bit so it's
not my normal opening so it can happen
him that you get to get a slightly worse
position oh why is he doing that this is
just just just a mistake i think give up
the bishop our 444 absolutely nothing
that also helps me to develop unless he
has some okay maybe he has some direct
idea I'm not threatening to take the
bishop I mean so like castling now or so
thing I can cancel long though now I'm
fine now that it was very helpful for me
that you took on its eggs yeah the
bishop what is the good square for this
Bishop c5 probably but I can wait for
one moment put the King on its normal
square and then go from go from there
yeah maybe start with root d8 is going
to see for her so well then this is a
good square no that looks like i have an
extra piece and play the king ok check
take it you can even go b5 now I can be
59 chick no let's start with no sorry
let's start with this one King f1 and
now
you
hmm
I just it is equal so just what it is i
was thinking i can maybe do something
because of my bishop it it doesn't
doesn't really net much
check
but I did not reckon I did not expect
that to happen Brooke f6 I don't know
that it is not clear to me if that it
really doesn't as much
he wants to go nightly five huh how
weird yeah what did i do right and then
he goes 95 I'm playing I playings just
badly here what what what am i doing it
this is just nonsense I'm starting here
in a better ending and then I'm then I'm
playing it so awfully that I'm worse
that's really fantastic ah really the
beginning this ending is just better for
black because my bishop is stronger than
his night by fire actually and then I'm
playing it in such a terrible way that
I'm did I get into this this is this
position I'm believable this stuff makes
me really sick I just played I just
didn't pay attention i think route d6
all of a sudden and now my bishop is of
course bad now because I can absolutely
attacking nothing
time morning ah Sonya black resign sorry
for the morning where this this is just
sick yeah you studying and better ending
and I playing this so terribly bad that
I'm losing in 10 moves I this is just
crap sorry yeah the descending is black
can absolutely never lose if it's not a
complete brain that idiot like I am in
this game ah come on I just didn't pay
attention that he can go go that to to
f6 yeah okay I'm it's okay up to here
but John I mean losing is completely
ridiculous not winning okay i mean it's
it's probably the engine gives equal but
if anybody black should should be able
to do something i can also just play
this was what i originally wanted to do
but this wasn't enough of me felt like
okay yeah i'm not having any realistic
winning chances which is probably true
but yeah this is i just did not pay any
attention i mean i thought okay 96
doesn't make any sense and I did you
just didn't see Luke f6 coming and this
is already raw already slightly annoying
that this happened and now you have to
be okay King d8 but should be a that's a
good defense but I was already too
pissed pissed off here that I got into
this yes how can you allow that it's
just terrible this is also needs to
completely brain dead move
[Music]
now I was just completely kind of put to
sleep here somehow I didn't didn't
didn't really realize that there was
something going on with Rudy cigs f6 hey
just annoys me like after move like a
bishop f6 to lose the game because this
is just like two terrible move it's just
terrible okay and then then you still
lose because you haven't even even
bigger more on there and be amazing no
but like it's look better I was really
thinking I could maybe do something here
but it's probably just an or two or two
symmetrical tough tough to to do
something to something active really
yeah no it's probably just a draw okay
thanks for watching